there are no shortage of wacky names for
alcoholic beverages from fuzzy navels to
sex on the beaches or Sexes on the beach
to the NSFW AMF I'm not sure if any of
these actually taste good or if they're
just fun to yell in a crowded bar
the origins of some are obvious While
others are more contentious two bars in
Juarez Mexico and one tequila
distributor in California are among
those claiming to be the Mastermind
behind the world famous Margarita which
was either named after a woman or a
flower depending on who you believe boy
if we can't even agree on the etymology
of an 80 year old word how are we going
to find ones that are 5 000 years old
fortunately or unfortunately humans have
been enjoying alcoholic beverages since
the dawn of civilization so there's
plenty of linguistic evidence in many
languages to point us to the truth as
the Roman said and we know where it us
I'm Dr Erica brazovsky and this is other
words
[Music]
other words
speaking of Vino in 2017 a group of
archaeologists discovered the earliest
known Winery in the world in an ancient
Village East of the Black Sea in what is
now Georgia Stone Age people were
growing grapes and fermenting the juice
8 000 years ago this is not far
geographically or chronologically from
the speakers of proto-indo-european a
hypothetical language that linguists
believe to be the ancestor of hundreds
of modern day languages from English to
Spanish to German Greek Russian Hindi
Persian Norwegian the list goes on and
on though this discovery is
archaeological evidence that the
proto-indo-europeans drank wine
historical linguists already knew this
to be the case how because many of these
languages still have similar words for
the beverage Vino Vine Vine owinos Genie
words that share a common ancestor like
this are known as cognates linguists
have even been able to reverse engineer
these cognates to reconstruct what the
ancestor word might have sounded like
loin though most people think of wine as
the oldest alcoholic beverage there is
actually something older slightly before
the Black Sea Winery was in production
Neolithic peoples in the Yellow River
Valley were making an alcoholic drink
out of fermented rice fruit and honey
honey may be the first ingredient that
humans ever fermented into alcohol
because unlike grapes rice or wheat you
don't need agriculture to harvest it as
depicted by some ancient cave paintings
the resulting beverage today called Mead
has a long list of cognates that show
we've been stealing from the bees for a
very long time the proto-indo-european
ancestor of all these cognates medu may
have been adapted from the proto-semitic
matak from there other non-indo-european
speakers likely borrowed the term as
well hence the Finnish messy
proto-chinese mitt and Japanese mitsu
that's a pretty prolific word
considering you don't see meat around
much these days unless you're one of
those people who brings it to parties
moving to the Beer aisle a craft
microbrew Aficionado might be able to
tell you the exact differences between
ales and lagers but the origins of those
words are more like a Hefeweizen than a
Pilsner
in that it's cloudy and opaque bad beer
joke ale is probably a Scandinavian term
for a malt-based beverage the word Aloo
appears on Ancient runic inscriptions
across Scandinavia often alongside
references to leaks suggesting that ale
was thought to have medicinal properties
some think the word is related to The
Latin Alum meaning bitter which would
make it a cognate with aluminum or maybe
it's connected to the Germanic verb Alan
which meant to grow or swell perhaps a
reference to the fermentation process
this would make it cognates with old
beer comes from the old English bayor
which some have suggested is related to
the word barley this seems unlikely
though since Bayer was originally a
sweet fruit-based drink it wasn't until
later that it became a synonym for ale
the more accepted source is a borrowing
of the Latin biberi which meant to drink
also where we get beverage and imbibe
lager is short for the German Lager beer
which meant a beer that was laid down or
stored for a long time it comes from the
pie root filet which also gives us the
word law because you can lay down the
law today the term laid down is still
used to describe the long storage of
alcoholic drinks I've got a few bottles
of the old wynyard left
by my father I know you're not supposed
to follow beer with liquor but let's
move on to the hard stuff the earliest
archaeological evidence suggests that
Muslim chemists were distilling wine
into a concentrated liquor in the 8th or
9th century alcohol actually has an
Arabic origin all cool a purified gray
powder used for cosmetic purposes the
practice spread to Europe where the
distillation process was seen as
extracting the very Spirit of wine which
was believed to have life-giving
properties hence the Latin name aquavite
Water of Life this term migrated to
several other languages like odevi in
French aquavit in Scandinavian okovita
in Polish and ishkabaha in Gaelic which
was eventually shortened to Whiskey some
linguists believe the term also
influenced the Russian vodka which
literally means little water as the
distillation process spread across the
world the resulting Liquors were
typically named either after their main
ingredient as in Gin and Rye or their
place of origin like bourbon and Scotch
the agave plant of Mexico is used to
make three different kinds of alcoholic
drinks tequila which is named after the
town of origin Mezcal which is named
after the plant from the nahuto meskali
and poke a sour milky beverage made from
Agave sap poke is the oldest of the
three originally called Oxley by the
mesoamericans who invented it thousands
of years ago the Spanish name was
probably a Corruption of a nap withal
term paluki Oxley which means spoiled
Oxley once you start mixing Liquors with
other beverages the result is widely
known as a cocktail although no one is
certain why one Theory refers to a 19th
century New Orleans socialite who served
mixed drinks in egg cups known in French
as Gutierrez another suggests it's named
after a horse's tail that has been cut
short as was the fashion with horses of
mixed pedigree now that everyone has a
drink they ordered it's time to raise
our glasses for a toast wait why is it
called a toast it can't really have
anything to do with twice cooked bread
can it actually yes there was an archaic
tradition of adding a small piece of
charred bread into your wine to add
flavor and soak up acidity
since this was typically done on festive
occasions you can imagine it to be the
perfect moment to say something special
before everyone takes their first sip so
whatever your poison or no poison at all
Salud
sarovia Kampai and cheers
moving to the Beer aisle a craft micro
boot microbrew a craft micro a craft
micro
a craft micro micro microwave micro brew